kanye dropped let's have on honest
conversation about it
let's go as opposed to just have an
honest conversation about it okay i
tried to listen
i was skipping a lot i had a couple
songs that were
um
fabio killed it on that [ __ ]
his verse was crazy did you listen to
that one which song was he on uh was it
uh
off the grid or some [ __ ] i know who a
lot of the features were goddamn songs
also he doesn't put the [ __ ] feature
yeah that was frustrating let me know
who's on what i think it was off the
grid um
but like i keep on going back to
i keep on going back to this is it pablo
no
you turned on pablo
and the first five or six songs
you just couldn't stop listening unreal
one after another transition and
everything beautiful boom
this wasn't that to me nope
i i'm just like drake the ball put it
this way the ball's in drake's court
yeah drake can get kanye the [ __ ] out of
here if he wants if if certified lover
boy comes through haymaker
he just goes like this bye little pip
squeak
see you later in my opinion
your guy's thoughts
i thought if he made it it was 27 songs
i think by the end he's just trying to
game
trying to game streaming and that
bothers me if you want to make a classic
if he had 12 songs on there i would be
like holy [ __ ] and this is where you
like i recognize kanye's jesus and his
uh his genius in that he had a song
things called lord i need you the one
about kim
how you can make a [ __ ] make me feel
this way about kim kardashian
who i've never liked i'm like yo this
this girl sounds great
this is his genius he can make this
emotional of a song about his ex-wife
but there's so many songs on there where
you're like i just i don't know what
what the [ __ ] is going on
and that's what got them it's beautiful
songs but also a lot of just filler
first listen i hated it
okay good first first listen i hated it
yeah uh too much lord [ __ ] too much
jesus [ __ ] i don't like the fact that
there's no curses on the album like i
want like give me the option give me the
uncensored version and give me the clean
version but the fact that there's none
um
second listen i [ __ ] with it okay yeah
so it's like i think it depends on your
environment when you're listening to the
first time i was just listening
headphones in the pool and i was like ah
this [ __ ] is mad long to get through
that's mag
so long second time i'm at the gym and
it's playing on a speaker sounds good i
would want to hear it on loudspeakers in
a car so that i put it on the phone on
the speaker on my phone as we were
coming back
from we just landed and we're coming
coming back from newark yeah
and
i press play and i'm like you want me to
play the speaker babe you could listen
and i just
and then it's like 15 seconds and my
girl's just like a minute it's a minute
so yeah i think part of it is that it
was that was just the pure auditory
experience and that there was like
visual elements that sort of went along
with it and that the whole album sort of
was like a show sort of i like the
listening party apparently i didn't see
it but like for like the donda chant it
was like a different picture of him and
his mom growing up
on every iteration of donda donda donda
and it was just like flashing images of
like him growing up with his mom and
then like his mom passing away so like
there was like a story within that song
to me that is like a skip like oh yeah
i'm not i mean to listen to this yeah
okay there was gonna be fire yeah
exactly but at the show it was like oh
there's actually a cool thing happening
like his his mom's name is now like this
word that doesn't even sound like a word
like so apparently in the live
experience it came across different than
just purely audio yeah yeah and that
happened
majority
by people who are not at the live stream
yeah only audio so it's like you're
curating something that isn't going to
satisfy the consumer right it's kind of
stupid
okay we're going but i'm assuming he's
just like a purest crazy person that's
like this is the way it has to be this
is the way the live show was and this is
the way i want it to be you make crocks
you make crocks you make crocks
that's what you do you make your money
on crocs
don't give me this purest [ __ ] [ __ ]
you make crocs
did you actually do a cross glow i don't
know no but that's what the sneaker is
like [ __ ] crap
you make crocs
right such bieber
haters
what you are a hater why am i hater son
he made something different
and the fact that he makes it cool you
don't like that you call yourself jesus
you call yourself the greatest [ __ ]
creator ever yeah he calls himself steve
jobs you know that sounds familiar
he's dead serious so once you call
yourself that [ __ ] you got to be open to
the criticism if he was like yo i'm mid
i'm regular yeah i'm just one of the
guys i'd be like bro you're a little
better than one of the guys bro like you
see these
crocs these are the most fire crocs i've
ever seen why would you say that these
are you're just a regular guy you took
crocs and you made them cool enough to
wear with jeans and [ __ ] but if you call
yourself jesus steve jobs and you just
made crocks with holes in them i'm going
to say that's who you are you set the
expectation for how people consume you
is that versailles what you were just
saying before he's cap but it's not cap
it's not cap
anyway like you you were saying yeah you
were so saying so i'm so i'm curious
about the live show like after listening
to it i listened to it twice and on the
second list it was kind of the same
thing but that's how all kanye's albums
are to me like the first time i listened
to pablo i was like oh that's cool it's
good
but then the second time i was like oh
yeah i'll listen there's no skips on
this the first time i was like i'll skip
a few seconds i think you could skip
pablo on the back of the back half or
back half maybe but now i love all those
tracks fair but like the first time i
listened to pablo number one i was like
this is [ __ ] unreal yeah dude
i wish that this album was is what
jesus's king was
ah so it's got a lot of the jesus stuff
in it i want like if you're gonna make a
gospel album that's dope but jesus is
king i was like i can't this is really
not even listenable like i did not enjoy
anything on here whereas this track had
like jesus influence but also like old
kanye and i was like okay that's a cool
way to approach a gospel album so make
this jesus king and so like i'm hoping
that's what he was trying to do he was
trying to do like the redemption thing
and then the next album is like more
like pablo and the rest of it but as far
as like a listening experience listening
to it all the way through i thought it
was like fun if you're listening like
you can't leave the whole thing yeah i
always do it at the gym but like if
you're listening intently like okay i'm
listening to this song i got into this
lyric there was one song like eight
minutes 45 seconds or something yeah i
mean i was on a flight so i was i also i
didn't get like the repeats like doing
like jail one jail part two and it's
just the same song but a different
feature i'm like
all right i know the jail one he he made
some i thought they didn't get jail too
i thought it was yeah
yeah because the baby there was
something going on but here's why
here's what i think people love that's
probably my favorite that's my favorite
song is the favorites jail one and two
are both fire okay jay-z's verse i
actually thought was pretty good jesus
versus the highlight of the album yeah
probably the baby's verse was good
that's the one thing i do like about
honestly it's great he brought the
features out and they came to perform
like i didn't feel like any of the
features really phoned in that's true
like all the features i thought slapped
i thought like the lauren hill influence
was cool even though it was like from an
old track yeah i thought lauren was
going to be on it
i was waiting for her verse because and
she's back out she was on nasa's album i
was like okay maybe she's back out
rapping now yeah i couldn't i was
waiting for that [ __ ] and then i was
disciplined i also hated the censoring
too yeah because now you're making me
add in the n-words
i'm like i think it goes there i don't
know you're making me do all the work
being like i don't know if that rhymes
with the figure like that like now i
gotta add it into the song that made me
uncomfortable kanye yeah i didn't like
it
i didn't even notice the sensor [ __ ] to
be honest
i thought i was listening to the sensor
version you know how they have like the
explicit that's what i thought too
but then he goes yo shout out to the
throw goats
and that was a sensor i was like all
right yeah
i mean
shout out to them
for real
i don't know what do you think again yo
sonically like uh or like music wise i
remember you saying on one of his last
albums you were like it just doesn't
even sound good like musically i thought
this did it seemed like he took his time
more so in that sense if you want to say
kanye is back yeah cool but as a rapper
it's just like
not really there's not he's not rapping
that great on it and also i think it's
weird to beef with drake where it's like
if you're kanye you seem to be moving
away from rap why are you going at this
rapper and making this a competition
it's a different thing your whole point
with fashion with fashion is i want to
make fashion that is universally
acceptable and these white people are
the gatekeepers but then when it comes
to your music you're still competing
with the black guy in the rap genre that
you say you're above competition for
like you're past this dude and drake is
probably gonna smoke you but like i i
think the drake angle is weird i think
when he dropped it and this is why i
think he doesn't have faith in the album
he dropped it and then said oh universal
put out my music without my permission
so if people say it's whack you're gonna
be like oh but they didn't have my
permission because the internet wasn't
really [ __ ] with it early on at least
yeah initial reaction on academics page
and
pretty much everybody but l-l-l-l yeah
and then then i see a post from him oh
universal didn't have my permission yeah
and then all the people that got left
off was interesting too soldier boy was
upset he got left off and the text
messages are there with kanye saying
like yo i love you you're a genius send
me a verse soldier boy there's a
screenshot of the verse and then he's
just not anywhere on the album
what about um
[ __ ] what was his face uh donald glover
is that his name yeah yeah glad that i'm
influential yeah what does that mean i
don't know necessarily i don't know if
he was talking about like
one of his like flows being bit by kanye
i wasn't sure exactly i mean he didn't
really come out and specified everybody
was all salty man i mean i think chris
brown was tweeting some [ __ ] or posted
on instagram you seen that yeah yeah
that's the only one i don't know why he
was upset because he was probably left
off too oh but like i'm wondering do
these people not know kanye well enough
yeah i know i think that they think
they're above that like they're above
being passed on what i thought would be
dope
is if
because kanye kind of did it like he had
marilyn manson he had the baby right
and if he had chris brown like what if
he took all these people
like if he's really about that
forgiveness [ __ ] he's really about that
jesus he's making uncool [ __ ] cool yeah
or no no he used to be mr uncle cool now
what if he's about like forgiveness and
rebirth
like truly about jesus and he takes all
these people that have done [ __ ] up
things in their lives and was like yo
here's the forgiveness song
or be part of this like this is about
rebirth like i he could i [ __ ] up i
was on that red hat [ __ ] and i was doing
all these things and i was living this
crazy life and that was [ __ ] up i
shouldn't have done it and now he's
truly using the power of jesus to help
these people be you know rebranded and
forgiven for their transgressions like i
thought that would i thought that's what
he was trying to do
so and then you know breezy not on it i
guess not everybody gets forgiven
you know like
it is oh it's kind of interesting so the
donald glover thing people are pointing
out that his album 315 20 was just a
white album cover okay whereas donna was
just a black album cover
so people were like that's one
similarity what was the white album for
the beatles what kind of cover was that
was that not just it was white and then
it just said the white album at the
bottom this was just a white square
and a black square
no blue squares straight these are no
square roots let's go trace it with the
blue square
i also thought the album cover was kind
of weird too
like i don't really get why i didn't see
that i don't know it just seemed weird
like it's the album's name after his
mother like the woman he loves the most
in his life and he's like what's the
album cover
black black
[Laughter]
he's like what can i do that would
remind me of my mom like
she was black i guess it's close
like come on dude
yeah i don't know i'm just unenthused
maybe there was some nothing that he
could do that would come close to his
admiration i think he's a little too far
gone
i don't think we're ever gonna have
the genius that we think kanye is like
he comes close to it but
it's still just
i don't think he got any more like i
think he's a little bit too far off yeah
he i don't think he was ever he was a
brilliant musician but this genius [ __ ]
that we put on him i guess he put it on
himself but we bought into it we were
idiots
the whole time i was like this guy's
just bipolar what are we doing of course
i'm i'm speaking musically yeah but i'm
just saying like i don't even think he's
going to make that great music like he
was once able to make
that's also the line with crazy genius
though right like it flips so quick
because they're so close to each other
you know what i mean like the guy that
just the giants mcgregor is a crazy
person now
yeah he was winning he was a genius
that's what i'm saying he's doing the
same behavior he just doesn't he's just
not winning and maybe maybe he was
always doing this behavior maybe he was
always tweeting these things maybe he
was always saying that he was and now
that
i think it's a little bit extra now he's
more desperate i think he's more
desperate but when he was saying when he
was winning wasn't desperate he was the
king yeah the king says whatever the
[ __ ] king wants yeah yeah
yeah but that's everyone anyone that
takes a crazy risk and then it works out
they're a genius and if it doesn't work
out you're crazy so it's like yeah he's
in his crazy spot but if he comes out
with another album later that smacks
then everyone's like oh yeah he's genius
again yeah that's the thing with music
is like you're just forgiven once it's
good
yeah it's it is the most intoxicating
form of content like a great song is a
great song it gets inside you in a way
it does man like a joke doesn't get
stuck in my head no i'm not
[ __ ] saying jokes to myself walking
down the street
music man i don't need anything i'm
there yeah now would you see him if he
comes live to new york no interest
really no i gotta say it live
the only reason
is
you should go just to see him put on a
show oh because what you want to do now
is put on
yeah but you said continue seeing it no
i thought it was mid
oh really it's kind of cool i've liked
every kind of uh show i've gone to like
it just he put so much effort into it
and i like i like people for a long time
my back gets hurt like let me sit down
like
i don't have to stand
like what's going on right now like
everybody
yeah i like live music but like start it
start it
like you gonna make people stand for
three hours and then you come on
like start it
if you want to make people wait at least
let them sit down bring some seating oh
so you were mad because he was late son
i once what was that fat girl who used
to sing a lot
no not fantastic girl from like
australia new zealand or some [ __ ]
huh remember she was like weird a bit
bjork nah nah nah anna gatsby
[Laughter]
she was kind of popping for a little bit
like lord lord oh lord smacks her oh but
she's not fat not at all she wasn't fat
no she was like 12. yeah she was 12.
you were thinking yeah i don't know but
like i remember watching one of her
shows like a girl i was with back in the
day want to see her live and like
i'm like standing for an hour and a half
before she even comes on oh yeah this is
not it right yeah like this is crazy how
you stand for an hour and a half young
people's game down like why can't we
just sit if i'm sitting i'm good
everything's fine people stepping on my
[ __ ] sneakers for an hour and a half
you're gonna get your sneakers stepped
on for an hour and a half before kanye
comes on
sing some trash songs
the best part of the [ __ ] whole
concert of the features they're not
gonna be there
like why would anybody go to this
everybody's going yo the feature's the
best part i can't wait to see the live
show who's there
i'm sure some of them will come through
not all for the experience if he doesn't
regard six features at the park
he does the garden the big ones yeah but
if you think the features are all
pulling up to indianapolis yeah it's
your goddamn mind bro but the garden
also have seats
not where when he does the pit when i
was there i saw him at the garden and he
had the pit
and i was [ __ ] exhausted i was like
ah all right
let's go let's go
drake's in a good place though
gotta do it right yeah and he's in a
great place he's like oh i get to hit
album i can see what people like don't
like about it i can still make tweaks to
mine
yeah i can i can have some bars coming
at you now she's gonna come out with
like club bangers that everyone's gonna
be like oh this is cool like and if it's
just gonna be better because it's gonna
be kind of different like the listening
experience is gonna be different he's
not i don't know if he's gonna innovate
in the way kanye tried to innovate it's
not gonna be as like unique but i think
the song is just gonna be consistently
yeah just give me some bangers dog
some [ __ ] bangers put a future on it
some bangers i could sit down to it yeah
listen to the music
you said you were at the gym probably
sitting down you know you were driving
sitting down you want a flight sitting
down sit down make sit down music yeah
what's up with all this stand-up music
right all these shenanigans
and they're standing why are these kids
standing all the time both of them 40
years old why didn't they even stand up
music yeah like think about you know
what
if i'm standing here
everybody stay seated there's just that
fire [ __ ] if i'm not everybody get
comfortable exactly no no no just
crossing the legs just for the weight
that's what i'm saying it's just for the
weight i'm okay if once you're out there
playing the music i'm ready to go let's
rip
but i'm not gonna do it after an hour
and a half of ours
bro yeah i know just show up late
because you know there's always opening
next like yeah
you never did a show before why did you
just say you could was never opened an
act for kanye yes it was not a pablo
it was just pablo so you just sat and
sat no no that doesn't make sense
what does it make sense so you were
there you were just sitting
standing in silence for an hour and a
half like nothing was going on no i
guess they were playing some [ __ ] huh
yeah the opening i was playing you just
probably weren't paid attention oh did
you see pablo
no i saw the one before he was playing
music or some [ __ ] but there was no open
act it was just him and remember there
was a stage that like moves across yeah
that was pablo right yes yeah so yeah
there was no opening act we were just
sitting there in the [ __ ] pit just
staring up at the bottom of his [ __ ]
sneakers
yeah
you got to stand up you sit on someone's
shoulders or something
that's where you gotta tap some of your
wood yo can i climb up yeah i would i
would literally do that at that point i
found a wall
and i just leaned out of your head
[Laughter]
let me lean please i was literally just
like anything dude connie's got four
more laps like that's the thing i'm okay
to stand if the music is playing we're
all dancing and partying but i'm not
standing for an hour and a half before
and then standing the whole [ __ ] time
that's too much
nice i didn't i didn't know that
nothing goes over how it happened
i was looking into buying one of them
seats that you could like take with you
to [ __ ] you know it's like you could
fold it up oh yeah www chair nah like uh
it's almost like a tripod but i got a
little seat yeah like a monopod i could
sit on